[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
[Musik]
hey zusammen wir fragen uns in diesem
Podcast heute was ist mit dem Bösen auf
sich hat wann es uns beherrscht wie tief
es in uns steckt und was es weckt ich
bin Toni Heyer und diese böse Geschichte
heute erzähle ich mit dem fabelhaften
Grund guten Mirko Kasimir hallo Toni
schön dass du dir da so sicher bist
Schatz beiseite heute gehen wir eine
Geschichte auf den Grund die im Winter
2017/2018 bundesweit Schlagzeilen machte
und viele Menschen berührt hat denn da
war das jung verheiratete Paar Ingo und
Stefanie P aus Schneiderin Franken das
verzweifelt Ingos Eltern suchte die sein
seit fünf Wochen vermisst die beiden
Laden sogar das örtliche Fernsehen ins
Haus ein geben am Weihnachtsbaum ein
Interview und bitten um Spenden für die
Vermisstensuche im Rückblick ganz schwer
zu ertragen Ingo erzählt eine Geschichte
darüber wie die Eltern verreisen wollten
sind nicht wiederkam sie waren beim
Packen von ihren Reisekoffern schon
gewesen zwei geplant dass sie verreisen
wollen und wir haben uns ein bisschen
unterhalten gehabt
was macht denn jederzeit da auch ihr
packt und war halt grob Aussage gewesen
ja die Reise geht halt einfach zu
Verwandten zu bekannten deswegen haben
wir da nicht mehr genau nachgefragt das
sind sie abgereist ist aber nicht direkt
mitbekommen eben leider Gottes auch
nicht wie sie abgereist sind doch
abholen lassen von Freunden von
Bekannten oder von anderen Angehörigen
oder vielleicht auch unten im Zug fahren
sind es ist alles schon mal vorgekommen
auch teilweise auch mit Taxi und man
kann sich auch leider nicht
nachvollziehen die Polizei ebenso nicht
23 war ich der erste Versuch mit diesen
anzurufen
ja leider ohne Erfolg schließlich äußert
das junge Paar rührselig die Hoffnung
alles könnte gut ausgehen ich habe die
große Hoffnung jeden Moment die Tür geht
unten auf die beiden kommen rein und der
Vater hat gleich seine Kamera dabei der
zeigt die Bilder vom Urlaub wo sie
gewesen sind und sagen halt einfach wir
waren halt irgendwie zwei drei Wochen
her gewesen
sein wenn man wenigstens wisst ihr was
mit ihnen passiert ist oder muss es sind
übrigens den Link zu dem Beitrag aus
frankenfernsehen TV findet ihr in den
schauen aus
Marco wir sind noch ganz am Anfang des
Falles und schon wirkt vieles merkwürdig
für uns doch gerne noch mal ein Ingo und
Steffi die erst seit dem mai 2017 ein
paar sind wohnen mit Ingos Eltern
Elfriede 66 Jahre und Peter 70 Jahre
zusammen in einem Haus in Schneider im
Nürnberger Land
Familienvater peter ist wegen Diabetes
schon lange Frührentner Informatiker
Ingo P ist Einzelkind und zu diesem
Zeitpunkt 25 Jahre alt er wurde als
Schüler wegen seines Übergewichts
gehänselt nahm als Junge Erwachsener mit
einer Diät kräftig ab galt unter
Kollegen als freundlich aber nicht
besonders teamfähig naja bis hierhin
noch nicht besonders aufregend nein und
so geht's auch erstmal weiter im
Frühling lernt Ingo über ein
Dating-Portal die 22-Jährige Stefanie
kennen sie kommt aus Burgthann etwas
mehr als 20 Autominuten von Schneider
entfernt
nach dem Hauptschulabschluss hat sie
eine Ausbildung zur Kindererzieherin
gemacht sie arbeitet dann in
verschiedenen Kitas die beiden sind
schnell ein festes paar und Steffi zieht
bei der Familie in Schnaittach ein okay
Mirko Informatiker und
Kindergärtnerinnen Franken von blutigen
Schlagzeilen sind wir an dieser Stelle
noch weit entfernt aber jetzt kommen wir
zum Verschwinden der Eltern Peter und
Elfriede tauchen ab etwa Mitte Dezember
2017 nicht mehr auf wie Ingo P und seine
damalige Verlobte auch im eben gehörten
Fernsehinterview Betreuern sind sie zu
einem Urlaub aufgebrochen haben aber mit
den Kindern kein Wort über ihr Ziel
verloren Nachbarn erzählt Ingo
zwischenzeitlich die Eltern besuchten
wohl Freunde in Kassel also ganz ehrlich
wie unwahrscheinlich ist das als ob du
deine Eltern nicht fragst wohin genau
sie verreisen Ingo macht sich angeblich
Sorgen als Weihnachten hat
er habe Verwandte und Bekannte am
telefoniert und die Eltern schließlich
als vermisst gemeldet
Weihnachten vergeht ohne die Eltern noch
Ende Dezember heiratet das junge Paar im
Januar entsteht das vorhin gehörte
fernsehen-interview Reporter Andreas
brettreich berichtet später schon auf
der Rückfahrt sei ihm der Fall komisch
vorgekommen und so ging es ja zum Glück
auch den Polizisten die den
Vermisstenfall bearbeiteten zunächst
fallen ihnen Ungereimtheiten in den
Aussagen von Ingo und Steffi auf später
aggressiver putzmittelgeruch und Spuren
von dilettantischen Bauarbeiten im Haus
schließlich wird eine offizielle
Durchsuchung angeordnet und jetzt geht
alles ganz schnell es kommt alles ans
Licht Werbung
was hat Sauce Bernaise mit Erregung
öffentlichen Ärgernisses zu tun und
kommt man wegen Oralverkehr während der
Periode in den Knast um diese und mehr
pikante Fragen geht es in der neuen sixx
Eigenproduktion Sex crime Stories Paula
im True Crime Fieber in insgesamt sechs
Episoden trifft six sex-expertin Paula
Lambert dem bekannten Strafverteidiger
Bestsellerautor und Podcaster dr
Alexander Stevens er berichtet von den
skurrilsten spannendsten und
schockierendsten sexuellen motivierten
Fällen seiner Laufbahn aber keine Sorge
das klingt jetzt etwas brutal aber es
geht in dem Format nicht um sexuelle
Gewalt viel mehr geht es um echte Fälle
die vor Gericht verhandelt wurden mit
überraschenden und skurrilen Wendungen
bei diesem Format verschlägt es sogar
der sonst sofortgewandten Paula Lambert
die Sprache auch ich muss sagen die
Fälle sind teilweise kaum zu glauben und
es gibt immer wieder viel zu schmunzeln
also verpasst nicht sexcrime Stories
Paula im truecrime-fieber ab 6 Februar
immer montags um 20 Uhr auf sixx
Werbung Ende
wir fassen das hier mal mit
Schilderungen aus der Pegnitz-Zeitung
zusammen deren Reporter Andreas
Kirchmeier viel über den Fall berichtet
hat auch dazu findet sich ein Link in
den Shownotes
am 22 januar 2018 finden die angerückten
Kripo-Beamten und Experten auf dem
Grundstück der Familie pillenschneider
hinter einer neu errichteten Mauer in
einem Anbau der Garage zwei Leichen
beide sind in Plastikfolie eingewickelt
in die Münder sind Plastiktüten gestopft
außerdem haben die Toten Plastiktüten
über dem Kopf die mit Klebeband
befestigt sind auf einem Klebeband
finden die Ermittler einen deutlichen
Fingerabdruck
in der pkw-grube dieser Garage befindet
sich außerdem ein Zimmermannshammer der
in blutverschmiertes Bettzeug
eingewickelt ist noch am selben Tag
werden Ingo und Steffi P festgenommen oh
mein Gott das ist so gruselig diese
Details mit den Mündern in den
Plastiktüten stecken und dazu dann auch
noch der Hammer aber okay das dreiste
übelst verlogene Lügengebäude von Ingo P
und seiner steffi ist zusammengestürzt
und sind wir ehrlich das hat auch nicht
lange gehalten jetzt wissen Polizei und
Öffentlichkeit wie sie mit Verlaub
verarscht wurden aber noch nicht warum
all das passiert ist dazu ein vorweg was
wir ab jetzt über den Fall wissen geht
aus den Ermittlungen der Spurensicherung
und der Gerichtsmediziner vor und aus
einzelnen Äußerungen Steffis bei der
Polizei und einem Haftrichter
beim Prozess aber haben die beiden
Angeklagten geschwiegen wir gehen jetzt
zum 14 dezember 2017 es wird heftig
Ingo schleicht sich zum Schlafzimmer wo
seine Mutter Elfriede schon schläft sie
liegt auf dem Rücken Ingo schlägt mit
dem Zimmermannshammer auf sie ein
mindestens 15 mal er verletzt sie so
schwer dass sie später perdien A-Probe
identifiziert werden muss an ihren
Unterarmen gibt es Abwehrverletzungen
sie hat sich am Anfang also gewehrt das
gilt erst recht für Vater Peter der war
wach im Haus unterwegs und hat offenbar
den Lärm gehört und kommt jetzt dazu es
entwickelt sich ein Kampf der sich über
den Flur des Hauses bis ins Esszimmer
zieht schließlich überwältigt Ingo
seinen Vater und tötet ihn mit
Hammerschlägen auf den Hinterkopf
ein Blutbad irgendwo in der friedlichen
spießigen fränkischen Provinz was muss
vorher alles passieren bis es zu so
einem Gemetzel kommt du hast ja nicht
eben die Tat eines wilden Psychopathen
an irgendwelchen Fremden geschildert
sondern das hier war der Sohn der seine
Eltern abgeschlachtet hat es sind
Aussagen von Nachbarn und
Familienangehörigen die ein Bild ergeben
und das sieht in etwa so aus Mutter
Elfriede und ihre künftige
Schwiegertochter Steffi können sich von
Anfang an nicht gut leiden
die Hausherrin hat einen Putzfimmel und
hält Steffi für schlampig
laut Staatsanwaltschaft soll Steffi bei
Ingo sogar schon vor ihrem Einzug darauf
bestanden haben dass die Eltern
irgendwann verschwinden müssen autsch
die Anklage ist außerdem davon überzeugt
dass hapg im Spiel war das Paar soll
Geldprobleme gehabt haben
Zeugenaussagen aber auch sehr gute
zeitungsrecherchen der süddeutschen und
der Pegnitz Zeitung machen klar beide
Ingo und Steffi hatten schon lange
vorher ihre dunklen Seiten
Ingos Ex-Partnerin Franziska sagt einmal
habe er ihren Kopf auf die Arbeitsplatte
in der Küche geknallt ein anderes Mal
habe er sie stundenlang der
Gästetoilette eingesperrt weil sie nicht
ordentlich genug geputzt habe den Vater
sagt sie habe er wie einen heiligen
verehrt die Mutter nannte er schon mal
blöde Sau und wünsche ihr verreckt doch
eine schrecklichen nette Familie und
Steffi auch über Sie Berichte dein
Ex-Partner sie sei extrem aufbrausend
nichts habe mir recht machen können sie
habe geprügelt mit Sachen geworfen
gekratzt toll da haben sich also die
Richtigen gefunden und ziemlich bald
nicht nur Ihre Hochzeit sondern eben
auch mal einen Doppelmord geplant und
das ganze ging offenbar noch viel früher
los als man bis hierhin hätte vermuten
können denn das Paar versucht 2017
zweimal die Mutter zu vergiften einmal
mit einem Muffin der mit toxischen
Pflanzensamen versetzt war das andere
Mal mit Liquid Extasy im Tee bitte was
beide Male kam Elfriede glücklicherweise
davon nach dem Muffin war ja übel den
Tee trank sie nicht aus dafür gelang der
hammermord ja umso gründlicher welche
Rolle hat dabei den Steffi gespielt das
wollte das Gericht natürlich klären fest
steht Stefanie P hatte in der Tatnacht
bei ihren Eltern geschlafen laut Anklage
war sie die maßgebliche Anstifterin und
nach dem Blutbad die Komplizin bei allen
zusammenarbeiten und Lügen
Steffis Verteidigung erklärt sie dagegen
zum Opfer und stützt sich unter anderem
auf einer Aussage der jungen Frau bei
der Polizei Steffi sagt darin sie habe
im Vorfeld der Morde nichts von den
Plänen ihres damaligen Verlobten gewusst
hinterher habe er sie gezwungen ihm bei
der Beseitigung der Spuren zu helfen er
habe sie eingesperrt und misshandelt man
sieht am Urteil dass das alles nicht
half in einem ersten Verfahren wurden
beide 2019 zu lebenslanger Haft
verurteilt Steffis Anwälte erwirken zwar
noch einmal eine Revision weil sie ihre
wirkliche Rolle beim Mord schlecht
begründet sein aber auch in der nächsten
Instanz gab es für sie wieder
lebenslänglich ich habe noch ein zwei
Dinge ausgegraben die sich später
ereignet haben die beiden haben sich
nämlich aus ihren unterschiedlichen
Gefängnissen noch Liebesbriefe
geschrieben seit 2021 ist damit aber
auch Schluss das Paar soll getrennt sein
und im Jahr 2020 ging es in der Justiz
noch einmal um das Haus auf dessen ein
Stück sich alles abgespielt hat ja
mittlerweile wohl eher ein Gruselhaus
das Landgericht erklärte Ingo P als
Mörder seiner Eltern Elfriede und Peter
P für Erb unwürdig Haus weg Frau Weg
Jahrzehnte im Knast ganz ehrlich das hat
sich nicht wirklich gelohnt womit wir
wieder am Anfang werden wie wird man so
derartig abartig böse naja darauf habe
ich natürlich keine Antwort aber
immerhin hat der Prozess gezeigt dass
beide offenbar schon vor dieser
Wahnsinns Tat falsch abgebogen sind also
aggressive Seiten hatten und das
Bedürfnis sich um jeden Preis
durchzusetzen auf jeden Fall und
vielleicht neigen wir alle dazu Pläne
die wir machen unbedingt durchziehen zu
wollen auch wenn sie noch so krankhaft
sind es scheint sehr schwer zu sein sich
da selbst Einhalt zu gebieten und zu
merken hallo ich überschreite gerade
eine ganz klare Grenze jaja Toni aber
vergiss mir die Liebe nicht in diesem
Fall wo er ungebremste Leidenschaft die
tragischerweise in einem mörderischen
waren endete
Ingo P wollte mit Steffi alt werden und
zusammen leben seine Eltern standen
dieser romantischen Vorstellung ganz
offensichtlich im Weg und da hat er
alles grub über Bord geworfen das
Unfassbare getan und seine Eltern
ermordet ja absolut man sagt ja auch so
schön liebe macht blind nur halt leider
auch negativen Sinne und ich kann mir
sehr gut vorstellen dass er im
Liebesrausch seiner Steffi unbedingt
diesen Wunsch erfüllen wollte wie
verblendet er dabei ist hat er wohl
nicht mehr mitbekommen ich meine das
sehen wir ja auch daran dass sie noch im
Nachhinein so skrupellos versucht haben
diesen Mord zu vertuschen aber Mirko du
kennst doch bestimmt auch das Lied
Banküberfall ne ja kenne ich findest du
auch dass das so enorm gut auf unseren
heutigen Fall passt ja das kann man so
sagen du meinst wegen der wunderbaren
Textzeile das Böse ist immer und überall
genau
das war's für heute schön wenn ihr auch
beim nächsten Fall wieder mit dabei seid
und vergesst nicht die Glocke zu
aktivieren und eine Bewertung zu
hinterlassen damit unterstützt ihr uns
total und wir freuen uns natürlich
mächtig darüber danke schön eure Toni
und euer Mirko wir haben den Doppelmord
von Schnaittach mit Berichten aus Bild
der Süddeutschen Zeitung der Pegnitz
Zeitung und dem franken Fernsehen
erzählt Skript Stefan netzebart
Redaktion und Produktion Stefan
netzwandt und Toni Hayer Postproduktion
Wake Word Studios München